gentlemen and ladies welcome to flappy
fedora and Yuma ladies out there who
love an alpha male like me and wants to
be rescued from the Neanderthal weakness
out there on the Internet
don't let them talk down to you like
that let a gentleman [ __ ] because as an
alpha male I am at the top of the food
chain I'm at the top of my intellectual
haven't done anything with my life
really doesn't mean I'm not going to I'm
very intelligent I'm motivated enough
I'm the best cat you can't get any
better than me not with those
Neanderthal it bros that you'd like to
hang out with ladies ladies be
fashionable fashionable just understand
that I'm on your side if you don't treat
me right I'm not gonna be on your side
much more you gonna cry on when you're
going to your oh your boyfriend was bad
to you oh no no I'm gonna be there for
you every day
I'm gonna be in your shower just to help
wash your back engaging in it so just
got a chance I mean like your best
friend we're best friends
come on so just talk it is just please
don't gentlemen and ladies how are you
doing on this euphoric evening I love
you so much mama look at me you got me a
man right in the bud